is the reality
i honestly i'm getting really emotional
it's been a little difficult
you know me you know me i stay strong
and i don't show it
but
but
i want to go back home
and i realized that i have
that i have uh i have the i have the way
to you know
maxim schmierkovsky gets emotional in
ukraine opening up about the russian
attacks in his home country
i realized that i have a different
passport and and my family is far away
and
what i'm realizing is that my friends
whose kids are here
whose moms dads are here and elderly
people are here and they can't just
just escape
the 42 year old dancing with the stars
pro shared two videos thursday morning
revealing he's in ukraine's capital city
of kiev where he's been filming world of
dance
ah yes i'm here i'm in kiev contrary to
what i probably should have done
a while ago but again everybody has
sources and
and resources and i have mine and i
trust my sources and no one saw this
coming
everyone was hoping that
the fight the
finality of the situation will be
averted right that there's not going to
be this kind of aggression
russia began attacking ukraine early
thursday morning after russian president
vladimir putin announced that he had
decided to conduct a special military
operation to protect eastern ukraine's
dobis region though globally this is
being viewed as a foreign invasion an
early act of war
i am not at this point someone who is
pleading
you know for someone else's safety from
a far distance from a safe distance i'm
somebody who's about to go into a bomb
shelter
because
it's going down
maxim shared a lengthy caption pleading
with those in power in russia to act
peacefully and resolve their issues with
ukraine quote there's always another way
war is never an answer i think the
russians need to get up and actually say
something because no one's opinion is
being heard
the dance pro adds that the attacks
bring back memories of his family
leaving the country back in the 90s
quote i will never be the same this is
stressful and i'm getting old feelings
back like i've done this before i
literally only just forgot about those
always on the edge feelings and actually
started worrying about things like
barbecue grills i'm crying as i'm typing
this because all man deserves to worry
about barbecue grills and not [ __ ]
war hug your loved ones
like i said i am i'm i'm uneasy i'm very
scared but i i know now
who these people are i know now who this
country is
what it represents what it stands for um
and it's completely not
what has been portrayed to the russian
people in order to
justify this invasion i'm gonna do my
best and trying to keep you informed
love you all bye